a former senior advisor to president
Trump's election campaign pleaded guilty
to charges of federal conspiracy and
making false statements the plea entered
by Rick gates on Friday says he will
fully cooperate with Special Counsel
Robert Muller's Russia investigation
gates is now the fifth person to enter a
guilty plea as part of Muller's probe
Paula Reid is at the White House with
more Paula good morning good morning the
gates plea caps off what has been a busy
week for the special counsel's office
and gates is likely to be a very
valuable witness for them as he had
access to the highest levels of the
Trump campaign and could provide
valuable evidence against his former
business associate and former Trump
campaign chairman Paul metaphors at the
federal courthouse in Washington Friday
Rick Gates became the fifth defendant to
plead guilty and special counsel Robert
Muller's Russia investigation gates
admitted to charges of conspiring
against the US and lying to federal
authorities in a recent interview with
investigators in October Muller charged
gates and former Trump campaign chairman
Paul Manafort with 12 counts related to
their lobbying efforts on behalf of
foreign governments on Thursday a
federal grand jury in Virginia returned
an additional 32 count indictment
against gates in Manafort for tax
evasion and bank fraud before he agreed
to cooperate gates was facing the
possibility of decades behind bars but
under the terms of his plea agreement he
now faces between 57 and 71 months in
prison and that could be shortened based
on his cooperation Paul Manafort has
done an amazing job the White House says
so far tried to distance the president
from his former campaign chairman and
his business associate saying back in
October the charges against metaphor in
gates had nothing to do with the
president or his campaign there are no
activities or official capacity in which
the Trump campaign was engaged in any of
these activities most of them took place
well before the campaign ever even
existed but Gates is now the third Trump
associate known to be working with
Muller's investigation
and his plea deal will put the spotlight
on manna fort who has given no
indication he intends to cooperate Menna
fort released a statement friday
reiterating his innocence and saying
gates decision does not alter his
commitment to defend himself against
quote untrue piled up charges if
metaphor decided to cooperate he could
provide special counsel with evidence
about that trumped our meeting with the
Russians that he attended and also why
the Trump campaign pushed to make the
Republican party platform more friendly
to Russia but so far no indication he
wants to play ball
he's expected to go to trial in the fall
Anthony Paula Reid at the White House
this morning thanks Paul up